welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka that spoiler
guy from YouTube and this video we're
breaking down some big new Easter eggs
found in spider-man into the spider
verse this list contains a ton of cool
little tidbits and things that have been
pointed out since our last video on the
film and as it's one of my favorite
movies ever any excuse to return to it
is good enough for me now throughout
this video we'll be breaking down all
the spider suits you might've missed the
crazy Green Goblin Easter Egg
Wolverine callbacks and a lot more there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't had a chance to check out the
movie yet then I highly recommend that
you all crawl your way out of here and
come back when you have you enjoy the
video then please drop a thumbs up and
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for breakdowns like this every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the new Easter
eggs in Spider Man into the spider verse
okay so the first Easter Egg actually
contains an amazing callback to the Sam
Raimi spider-man films you may have seen
that when creating the soundtrack for
the Winter Soldier the composer actually
took the screams of Bucky from the First
Avenger and slowed it down and made it
the winter soldiers theme
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
something similar also happens in enter
the spider-verse
and the green Goblin's scream from the
rhyming movies is used for the theme of
the Green Goblin in this one
[Music]
on top of this there are also callbacks
to other Marvel characters throughout
the film when the Prowler is chasing
down miles through the subway he opens
his claws and we can see that the sound
effect they give is a snikt snikt is of
course the onomatopoeia sound that
Wolverines claws make when he brings
them out it's a cool at least a reg that
kind of gives you a brief idea of just
how sharp that the prowlers quotes are
and yeah you don't want to bump into
this guy ever now speaking about the
characters the movie of course lets us
know that within the spider-verse there
exists several versions of Peter Parker
the first one we meet tells us that he's
the only spider-man however if you pay
close attention to the signs in the
background you will see one that says
wrong and this is to subtly let us know
that the character is well wrong the
universe in the film is also earth 42
and we know this because the number
itself is dotted throughout the film I
already went through this in my last
breakdown and discussed how there were
certain signs that things were wrong in
the world such as movies that hadn't
been released as well as chants the
rapper's hat containing the number four
instead of three well in addition to
this in Times Square we can also see
that snapchat is called Picabo and when
miles hands in his test at one point in
the film the day at the top says
December where II which of course shows
us that in their world the months are
slightly different to ours the movie is
full of subtle little details including
language knots and the use of text
on-screen to demonstrate what character
is thinking or doing there's a brilliant
bit in the film in which the Japanese
text for I'm scared appears on penny
Parker's spider robot and this shows
just how much thinking the creative team
put into the movie penny is also dubbed
instead of subbed and thus when she
talks her lips are slightly out of sync
with what she's saying on top of this
there's a hilarious thing that the
producers do with miles to make sure
that the movie can get a PG rating when
were first introduced to the character
he sings the song sunflower by post
Malone instead of seeing the line she
wanna ride me like a cruise miles
mumbles through the song and says she
want to drive me so yeah
kepta PG there'll be no talk of riding
here in our last video we talked about
how Doc Ock had octagonal glasses which
of course tied into her name but this is
also included in the design of the
furniture around her room the lights
that hang from the ceiling are also
octagonal aka eight-sided and this is
some really nice attention to detail
that shows just how much the animators
were tying everything together and
finally I thought I'd break down all of
the suits that we see in this spider
cave everyone dropped the ps4 one on the
last video which we can of course see in
the background and this also appears at
the end of the movie in the credits
scene at one point making for a cool
Easter egg along side it also appears
the rubber one which Spiderman used to
fight Elektra within the comics there's
also a costume with a cape and is
possible that this is a callback to the
start of the movie when we see that in
miles is room as a picture of a
superhero with a cape above his easel
you also see what looks like the iron
spider sit from the Civil War comic book
run and this was later referenced at the
end of homecoming which is when we got
our first look at it before it popped up
in Avengers infinity war we can also see
what looks like the stealth suit which
was introduced as a way to avoid the
spider-slayers
and since then a lot of the time when
the character needs to go incognito
there's also the mark 2 which Peter
ended up making after he lost his spider
sense and needed more protection for his
body it's covered in a very fine layer
of armor that makes it bulletproof but
since getting a spider sense back he
sort of stopped using it was also the
empty empty mannequin with a noose light
on because as we know what the character
he never came back that night anyway
that's all the extra details that we've
noticed since doing our first breakdown
on the movie obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on these Easter eggs and
if you want to watch our other video
that goes about all of the film's insane
details from start to finish and make
sure you check it out after this it's
our most in-depth video ever ever ever
so definitely give it a watch if you
want to support the channel from as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below
we massively appreciate you and there's
a thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat - so after
the show either follow us that heavy
spoilers or click the discord link in
the description below every month we
give away free movies to people our
subscribe to the channel and this Monty
come on the MCU infinity Saga box set
and all you have to do is comment on a
video and make sure you subscribe with
notifications on the winners gonna be
chosen at random on the 15th of July in
the cell be shipped out from then to
ever gets the price so best of luck to
everyone who takes part and thanks for
watching the video take care peace
[Music]